everyone can take and there's
photographers out there that take
pictures way better than my photographs
of like landscape and animals and I'd
rather I'm not competing but I'd rather
take my own take on these things that
are not easily comparable it's even like
my life as an investor or a entrepreneur
I just never felt like a like I was like
other entrepreneurs I just always had I
was doing it was like a photographer and
I was doing other things so maybe my
approach to life is to not do it the way
other people are doing it because I
don't want to be compared to them I'd
like it to be more unique and I know
they can do better than me so
[Music]
you